أجنبي
محنك ويتم ترشيحه كل يوم ولكنه لا يزال
يحتوي على جزيئات من عام 1912 بالدرجات ،
أنا كيندال روبرتسون صاحب
الإطارات العالمية الشهيرة في بيل في ممفيس
تينيسي ، نحن مشهورون بشحومنا ،
فنحن نطبخ جميع البرغر لدينا في اليونان.
طوال الوقت ، لكنها لا تزال هي
نفسها الأصلية التي
أنشأها Grease elmer.guyer Dyers في عام 1912 عندما
كان في شارع كليفلاند في ممفيس.
القصة تذهب يومًا ما
نسي أحد موظفيه إفراغ
المقلاة في الليلة السابقة لفتحه و
سرعان ما استقطب العملاء
وبدأت للتو في طهي البرغر في المقلاة التي
كانت تحتوي على شحوم من الليلة السابقة
وكان العملاء هكذا هو
أفضل برجر تناولته على الإطلاق في حياتي
ولذا ولد دايرز
إطارات ليست مثل أي  المطاعم الأخرى
ليس لدينا شواية ، ليس لدينا سطح مسطح ، لدينا
فقط مقلاة مليئة بالدهون ،
اسمي غنائي معروف أيضًا باسم
رجل البرجر ، يوضح لكم يا رفاق كيفية صنع
تنورة للحمية ، نقوم بتجميع اللحم ونقوم
ببعض الكرة ونحن  سوف تستخدم
مطرقة خشبية وملعقة فولاذية
لتسطيحها ، عليك التأكد من
أن الملعقة مغطاة بالشحوم
حتى لا تلتصق الباتي بالطريقة
نفسها ، فلا يوجد
متوسط ​​نادر نادر.  كل شيء
جيد ، وعندما يطفو ، انتهى الأمر ،
انظر كيف تطفو هنا ، كل
كعكة تأتي مع مخلل الخردل والبصل
أيضًا الفلفل الأسود في الجزء السفلي منها ،
وهذه هي الأنظمة الغذائية التقليدية حيث يكون
لدى Dyers توابل خاصة ولكن لا يمكنني
إخباركم  ما هذا وهنا يأتي The
Magic Pot ، هذا ما
يحب الجميع مشاهدته
كما ترون ، نضع الجبن في الأعلى
للتأكد من أنها تصبح جيدة ولزجة
وذابة تمنحها مثل نكهة زبدانية للغاية
عندما تقضمها
و  ثم إنه أول برجر لطيف لك
عندما تقضمه ، كل ما
تريده في الهامبرغر حصل على
هذه الإضافات المختلفة ، إنه أشبه
بلطف قليلًا من البرغر تقريبًا بسبب
الثمار التي كادت تذوب في فمك
كانت واحدة من أفضل البرجر.  لقد
حصلت على هذا في العالم من أي وقت مضى ،
إنه أمر بسيط للغاية وسريع وسريع ، لم
أجرب أبدًا أي شخص يجرب برجر الدولار الذي
لم يعجبه حقًا
[الموسيقى]